اذا رجعت انا على حارتي ش استفدت انا
صاحباتي ماتوا في حارتي اسمي سهاد دياب
عمري 13 سنه نازحه من منطقه ال 17 لتوام
شمال غزه بعد الحرب حياتنا تزمت من كل
النواحي طبعا لا عننا هلقيت حق سكن لا
عننا حق الامان لا عننا حق ذهاب وتنقل ما
عندنا ولا اي حق من هذول حقوق الانسان
كطفله صغيره
بالعمر طبعا بعد الحرب تعزمنا انه احنا
كيف طلعنا من بيتنا طبعا رموا علينا دخان
ونحن اختنقنا فا ابويا الله يطول بعمره
حكى لنا اجهزوا والبسوا ضبوا اغراضنا طبعا
مش كل اغراضنا اخذناهم لانه الوقت غير
كافي لازم ننحي حالنا قبل ما نموت قبل ما
نختنق ومعنا كمان اطفال صغار اخواتي لي
ثلاث اخوات صغار واخو كبير لكن عننا ازمه
ما في التنفس صار لمينا اغراض بسيطه على
يدنا وطلعنا بالسياره طبعا طول السياره
كان ابوي يحكي لي تشاهده ما كنا متوقعين
اصلا اقل من نص ساعه كنا حنموت يعني من
الريحه طبعا قبل ما نوصل على المنطقه اللي
احنا احنا هلقيت نازحين فيها قعدنا في
الشوارع ظلينا في الشوارع مده طويله بعدها
انتقلنا لهذه المدرسه اللي احنا عايشين
فيها حاليا اصلا هذه المدرسه ملوثه
بالكامل لا يوجد حمام لا يوجد اكل لا يوجد
شراب لا يوجد مكان ان نجلس به هنا انا
نفسي توقف الحرب ونفسي يكون عندي بيت اعيش
فيه حاليا لانه بيتنا تدمر اذا رجعت انا
على حارتي ش استفدت انا صاحباتي ماتوا في
حارتي انا ما عنديش دار انا ما عندي شارع
انا هلق ما عنديش مدرسه ما عنديش مكان
اروح فيه ما عنديش ميه ما عندي شرب ما
عنديش مكان امن هلقيت انا فيه انا بطالب
حقوق الانسان بتحكوا عن حقوق الانسان وين
الامم المتحده المدارس المدارس انت كنا
نتحامى فيها قصفها وين
الامان